in about 2004 I was talking to a buddy
of mine a guy named Tom schnaus we'd
been out of work for two years I said
you know what are we going to do now and
he said why don't we get a uh Winnebago
uh Caravan I guess in Australia why
don't we get a caravan and uh you know
put a meth lab in the back of it and
ride around America and see the sights
and cook math make some money and in the
moment he made that joke uh this sort of
little Eureka moment hit me because I'm
a very boring law-abiding guy and and he
is too despite his sense of humor and it
it it dawned onto me as he was making
this joke that would be an interesting
character to write about someone like us
who for whatever reason actually did
such a thing actually decided to to cook
meth and then I thought well you know
you gotta you gotta you must need money
and and one thing led to another and by
the time the phone call was over uh that
moment of inspiration had had led to I
didn't have a name for him yet but led
to that character who would eventually
be known as Walter White